welcome to agile tutorial from simply
learn i am cmr
chandra mr a professional consultant and
coach
certified agile scrub master pmp
principal practitioner
itl for managing professional kobit 5
and devops as part of this video
tutorial we are going to understand what
is agile
let us look at a time in the late 90s
what was happening with
software development forms so they used
to follow waterfall methodologies
so there is to be expression like sir we
have a problem
so what happened so our client want a
new feature to the software
we are already midway creating the
software we can't add
the feature so what does it mean so
there is a scenario where the change is
asked
so why change change may be because of
adding certain features
removing certain features modifying
certain things already given
what is wrong in that why can't we do
the change so now
point here is not about doing the change
itself it's about the effort
additionally it takes
cost money in terms of which is going
out
the effort then the scope which is going
to change
at the same time you also need to put
more efforts which will
delay the project so now is it okay
so 90s it was okay today is it okay
a big question mark so why is that not
okay so may it understand that very
clearly
right i knew we should not have used the
waterfall methodology for development
so is that an issue with the waterfall
methodology
so answer is no if it is today's
scenario
the answer would be yes if it is 90s
answer would be no
so what changed in this 20 years or 15
years
the dynamics of the market changed the
behavior of consumers changed
so if you look at anyone who is using
any product it may be a software product
or a hardware
like if your mobile phone or a
television or any application mobile
application or
application used on your systems the
upgradation of the new features and
functionality of that is
improved more and more and consumer
wants it more
and you have a very less time to respond
that is one thing
second thing there is lot of competition
if you do not respond quickly
competition will take over
so for you to sustain and grow it is
very essential
that you understand this dynamics and
you need to respond quickly
which was bit difficult when it comes to
approach what is called waterfall model
now how do we address this so what is
that waterfall model is
all about why is it difficult for us so
the methodology where waterfall
model is used involves teams following a
series of steps
and only going forward after the
previous steps are
completed so there is a wait time
involved so until the previous steps are
completed only then i can move to the
next
so it is a slower thing it would take
certain
longer duration so it is best used in
the scenarios where the teams are small
and the project is expected to move in a
predictable manner so predictability is
very important when we follow waterfall
methodology predictability
the variation should be as lesser as
possible so what is the predictability
i'm speaking about
as i create this product as a result
comes up if it takes six months one year
two years three years it's okay so this
is how the product would look like
the predictability how the product would
look like how that particular output
would come so when is that going to come
is it okay
if i bring that result after two years
is that okay
so if everything is okay that way
without very less without any variations
as such very less variations
then it's fine so because of following
waterfall model
what is that methodology what is that
flow we need to understand that
so requirements gathering and
documentation is the first thing what
used to happen which is true in agile
methodologies also
but the main difference here is the
requirements gathering and documentation
happens in detail a comprehensive one
now once that is signed off only then it
is more to the design
now based on that requirement which is
gathered which is full comprehensive
then the design will happen based on
that the consideration of process
the products the people the environment
then the design happens which is again a
detailed design
now once the implementation starts if
you find any deviations
the correction needs to be done since
the design is in detail
the deviation possibility is as less as
possible
but the challenge comes up when the
dynamics in the market when the dynamics
of customer
changes customer asks for change then
you may require to do the change
now when you want to do that change you
might require to do
the change only after understanding what
would be the impact of this change in
the
entire output which you are going to
create which is very comprehensive one
so because of this it consumes time it
consumes extra effort
so it may be a scenario where the scope
of work is reduced as well
even after that this exercise has to be
done which will delay the project
so this was okay so when this model when
uh
things were done things were taken up
for changes it was okay because the
consumer behavior as i mentioned
there is a lot of wait time for the
consumers also so there was less
competition but today it is not i need
to go quicker
so because of this what are the
disadvantages which just came up
to the consumers or to the organization
who actually follow waterfall
methodologies in today's scenario
so what could be those so making changes
would be difficult as i mentioned uh
earlier so then it doesn't focus on end
user client
customer perspective value so today i
think more and more we're speaking about
creating a value in the consumer
perspective customer perspective and the
time it takes for
consumer to realize the value how long
it takes the more it delays in realizing
the values by the consumer
there is a delay in terms of making your
product impression better in the
consumer's mind
so competition will take over so your
existence will be in
bigger threat so testing phase is
delayed until most of the project is
completed
because it has to follow step by step
wait the things to complete and then
testing happen then measuring the
progress within the stages is
difficult so why is it difficult
measuring the progress within the stages
because the deliverables or the metrics
what are defined are defined to
measure at a milestone and at a end of
the phase to understand whether
everything is delivered as part of it
now let us look at how agile is going to
help us
to address these disadvantages mentioned
in what fall model
so what is agile the basic meaning of
agile is to move faster be flexible
respond to change etc but to accomplish
this there are a lot of methodologies
now there is something called agile
manifesto on 12 principles of agile
which we need to understand so
following this accomplishing this can
only help us in becoming a child
so in 2001 agile was introduced
so that's where the term agile came into
picture where people start realizing
what is agile
and why should we adopt that agile
methodologies so while it was
introduced so agile manifesto was also
released
it's a set of principles used in project
management and software development
so basically there are four points which
we need to understand very correctly
very clearly so that we can able
to understand what is agile is all about
right it enables team to deliver value
to their customers with ease
so agile team deliver work in small but
usable increments
then evaluation of the requirements
plans and results takes place
continuously
this allows teams to respond to changes
quickly now change was one of the
scenario what we were speaking about
now responding to change quickly is one
of the disadvantages what we spoke about
and here it is addressed it is
considered to address that is very
important
now when we respond to change quickly it
is not that i just quickly responded but
i did not address that problem or that
scenario
it is very essential to address that
scenario as well effectively and
efficiently
so now agile is a concept right
so it has a detailed manifesto based on
which all the agile methodologies are
created
so what is this agile manifesto is all
about so it is created it was created
during february
2001 so which details out the values and
principles of agile processes
which says there are some values which
is mentioned in the left
which has more weightage compared to the
one which is in the right
now when we say this for example let us
take let us go one by one
individuals and interactions over
processes and tools
so are we saying we don't value the
process and tools
that is not the case now let us look at
what were the typical
issues or challenges anyone would have
expressed regarding the processes
so delay may be bureaucracy and
they cannot have a flexibility to move
faster so basically delays because of
the approval which is not happening
because of the processes
now how do we address this so can i
eliminate the process itself
answer is no because in the absence of
tools and processes
none of the things which we can do
easily can exist
so it should be there process and tools
should be there the way it should be
defined it should also ensure there is
individuals and interactions encouraged
to have their individuals
and interactions while having the
process and tools so next is working
products or comprehensive documentation
so when we say comprehensive
documentation as i mentioned in the
waterfall methodology during the
requirement gathering during designing
there is a
detailed documentation which is made so
which take lot of efforts in creating
those
now while delivering the challenge what
anyone was faced was
the change which is coming up and making
changes to these documentations which is
an additional effort
now if we have a working products if i
have a bigger product
in that a module of that i keep creating
every small small modules of it and
start integrating to the base model now
i will only focus on the documentation
for that particular model working piece
which i am going to create in the next
iterations
then my documentation changes are less
and also the way i'm making the
documentation is initially i would have
a full skeleton of the entire product
which i'm going to create
the roadmap and upon that i'm going to
making the detailed documentation for
that only for that working piece rather
than the full product itself
then these working piece documentation
which i'm going to create
as i create the working pieces i'm also
getting the feedback because i'm doing
the interactions with the users the
consumers the end users
so i get the feedback i keep making the
changes quickly and then documentation
will become accordingly
the small pieces of documentation which
happens with those small small small
working models which are created
and those are consolidated over a period
of time by the time the product
ends you have a comprehensive
documentation the project hands you have
a comprehensive documentation
so it saves lot of time so documentation
is important
but the way we accomplish the
documentation is one by one not in one
go
next is customer collaboration or
contract negotiation
so any engagement or any relationship or
any business can it happen in the
absence of contract
answer is no there should be a contract
now how this contract should be when we
want to follow an agile it should allow
the customer collaboration
why are we collaborating to understand
what customer is required
to understand what customer needs is
fulfilled
right so now this requires a lot of
flexibility in the contract itself
so that commercial is one area which
gets impacted and there should be
guidelines for that also in the contract
so that during the collaboration during
the change during the effort being put
customer is also informed what is the
change which is going to happen in terms
of commercial
as well as time and everything so that
it is documented in the contract so
there is no confusion
responding to change or following a plan
now we cannot have a rigid plan as we
were speaking about
waterfall methodology so that we need to
go like this only
so based on the scenarios changes so we
require to change your directions and
move faster so responding to change
requires a specific flexibility which is
required in the plan
so that you i don't have a plan which is
very rigid and that
provides some flexibility that's how i
can able to create my plan so that
i can able to move or respond to that
specific scenarios which are
changing so this is called agile
manifesto
and this agile manifesto has 12
principles
associated with this now keeping this
agile manifesto on 12 principles
all the agile methodologies have created
their own approaches
and framework now let us look at what
are those 12 principles the agile
principles
so agile principles so here are some of
principles that need to be followed to
make a processes
agile so first principle is about
customer satisfaction
so one need to satisfy the customer
through early and quick delivery of the
product
now someone who is hungry if you give
them a water
or a food immediately a piece of bread
at least there is some satisfaction
there is some realization as i got it
what i need
so energy is back so it is very much
required to ensure
seeing things in a customer perspective
and customer is satisfied
so customer satisfaction is not a result
of the survey what i do
it's about how i deal with the consumer
what is that impact the perceptions i'm
building with the consumer and what do i
know about my customer
do i really understand the pulse of my
customer how associated am i how close
am i
how am i collaborating with the customer
that will help you to understand how
satisfied your customer
it is very essential to consider
customer satisfaction and the second
principle would be welcome change so
changing needs
need to be addressed even late in the
development process so change can happen
anytime now these changes should not
become a challenge
so there should be a flexibility in your
design itself which will bring in
so that is the reason i think when you
move faster so
it doesn't mean that you eliminate or
you just keep introducing the defects
and move faster no that is not allowed
so whenever there is a change in the
feature whenever there is a change to
some
specific product functionality
accommodating that should become easier
whatever the methodology i follow
that should help me in terms of
accommodating so i should be welcoming
changes it's okay for me to have the
change
so that is not a challenge anymore for
me so principle three
deliver frequently so ensure software is
delivered frequently focusing on
shorter time skills as i was mentioning
while discussing the manifesto point
like i keep creating a smaller piece of
product modules
so that i keep putting into the base
model and integrating those
and ultimately once all the features
functionalities are integrated
we have a product with all the features
and functionality
so this needs to happen more frequently
so the release of those
working p should happen more frequently
more repeatedly
so that customer is seeing those working
fees and experiencing
and giving their feedbacks so quick
changes to those working piece making
that will become easier
then work together so when i work
together it is very essential
that developers and business individuals
need to work together through the course
of project
which means involvement of customers
involvement of suppliers
involvement of your own team everyone
should work together each one should
understand
each other's perspective view if there
is no proper understanding about
each other's perspective view it is
quite obvious what was expected what was
delivered would not match
so there should be correct understanding
to have that correct understanding one
should work together collaborate
so they should speak express which is
very important
so feedback has to be given by consumers
regularly
similarly the organization who is doing
the project should also keep giving the
feedbacks to the suppliers to make
necessary changes
and once it works together in a unizone
i think that would help in terms of
bringing out the results the way it is
required that would help customer to
get the value motivated team so projects
need to build
around motivated individuals and they
must be trusted to get the job done
means
when will the team get motivated when
the work what they are doing
is acknowledged when the work what they
are doing the results are
seen experienced and then feedback is
given
there is an opportunity for learning and
contribution their contribution is
acknowledged
only then team is motivated when there
is a motivated team
when team feels there is someone with
whom they can look up to
it's quite obvious team will also come
up with certain set of innovation in
their mind
giving their feedback as well involving
themselves in terms of getting the
results what is required
so it is always essential to ensure the
team which is
involved in creating the products is
always motivated
so i think when we say team the conflict
also come across
there may be a clash between the various
different thoughts and preferences
so one cannot just shy away being a
manager one cannot shy away from it
he or she should involve sit with the
team resolve those put things in the
right direction so right
lead interpersonal skills are very
important here next face-to-face
interactions
so which helps in terms of most
efficient means of communication which
helps in terms of giving a proper
clarity in terms of what is required
so that i sent an email i expect the
person to do it that is not the case
what we're discussing about
so more and more interactions which
should happen face to face so that each
other understand what requires to be
done
and there is a quick feedback which can
happen when that particular interactions
conversation which keeps happening
so one can understand other perspective
view as well
then working software so it is a
primarily the deliverable which you are
speaking about which has to come
regularly so more and more working piece
as it comes
customer can give feedback based on
their experience on this working piece
instead of just imagining something and
then giving the feedback
so it should not look like an hypothesis
or something which is in the dreamland
so i told something
the person who heard visualize something
else it should not end up that way
instead of that give the working piece
expect the consumer the user to give the
feedback
so that it helps in terms of creating
that particular product ultimately which
is
usable and which is going to create
value to the consumers
so next is constant pace so agile
process promotes sustainable development
so
it should not i did it and i sleep i did
it and then i'm waiting for something
else
no there should be frequent deliverables
which is happening so there should be
constant
moment from left to right from beginning
to end so that
the deliverables which are expected
keeps happening
so that consumers or users are realizing
the value of it
so it should be constant pace the
velocity the speed which needs to be
adopted then good design agility can be
improved by focusing on technical
excellence and good design
so when we say technical excellence and
good design it is very essential to
understand
insight towards what is that product
being delivered
insight towards what is the technology
being used insight towards the processes
the capabilities skills
so all this comes together when people
sit together and
focus on creating that product or
services so they are putting the effort
towards
designing it appropriately so that that
will fit for purpose
so since things are moved step by step
in terms of creating a working piece
the detailed designing of that small
working piece would happen which can
happen quicker as well
and since these are going and fitting
into the architecture which is basically
open
architecture kind of scenarios what
you're speaking about so all those
modules what you create you keep
plugging into it
so that you were designing that small
piece which is quicker so instead of
designing the entire system as a whole
in detail you're just creating that
small null pieces and fitting into that
architecture which is open
so pluggable so that gives flexibility
as well
and changes to the design will become
easier if it's not working
and agility helps in accomplishing that
simplicity the amount of work that's not
being done needs to be minimized
meaning when we say simplicity doesn't
mean less
right so the appropriate number of tasks
the minimum number of tasks which needs
to be done
and mostly i think all non-value-adding
activities and processes would be
removed
it has to be removed so the more
optimized more simpler in terms of
handling things is always good
so that only those what is required to
be done are done so it is very clearly
visible and there will be clarity
self-organization so when we say
self-organized teams
who is not capable of everything but
when you look at a team has a whole each
one has
different different skills many skills
not one or two skills many skills which
they are complementing to each other
so they come together they discuss
together they focus on the architectures
requirements and design
and address it together so team is also
owning the ownership is one thing when
it comes to picture when you say team
so here since team is actually taking up
that ownership and organizing themselves
to accomplish the results
the products what is required so then
obviously the results will happen
the way it is needed and they will
become accountable as a team so they
cannot have a blaming scenario where
because of one or two members it is
happening they should collaborate better
they should be self-organizing what
should happen
so next is reflect and adjust
so when are we going to reflect reflect
upon what is that happening
learn understand keep learning it having
a reflection to that what is happening
means responding to that so that
improvement can happen quicker
effectiveness can be improved by the
team regularly reflecting on it
so team is also understanding team is
also having that accountability to
ensure that necessary adjustments
necessary actions are taken to make
those changes and connections quickly
so these are about 12 principles so
which supports
which helps that accomplishment of
manifesto points
the four manifesto points what is
mentioned so keeping these
four manifesto points for values which
is mentioned in manifesto and then
12 principles so keeping this in mind
any agile methodologies have their own
approaches
and they accomplish all of this so
further let us look at some of the
advantages what would be there when
following agile so we looked at the
disadvantages what we have when we
follow waterfall
so did we overcome those the
disadvantages what we had in
waterfall did we overcome that using
agile so what are the advantages of
agile
so agile is helpful in terms of
handling large amounts of interactions
between client and project team
because it is throwing lights on it so
importance of interactions the
importance of
collaboration the what is that
self-organized teams
it is spoken more and more then improve
transparency to claims in
every phase of the project how this
transparency because customer is seeing
those
products the products with features and
functionalities are seen
they're experiencing it and based on
that they're giving the feedback there
is nothing something hidden like
when i go with waterfall till the end of
the project
customer don't know what is going to
come out as a whole
but here since the working piece is
given regularly
customer is seeing it the users are
using it and giving their feedback so
interactions increased
so visibility towards what we are
creating results is more
right then the delivery of the output is
predictable
and can sometimes be earlier than
expected
because we know what is being delivered
more and more clarity users are
obtaining
at the same time the team which is
creating is obtaining because of it
the pulse of the customer the directions
are clear accommodating changes which
was the challenges in
it was a big challenge in waterfall
methodology has become easier here
so then the cost of the project are
predictable and follow a rigid schedule
so it is very easy to handle the
schedules because
more and more you interact and more
iterations are in
creation of small small working piece of
a product working model of the product
so now as you progress in that you
understood the environment better you
understood the clients better the
customers better
the expectation better and moving faster
so that will become easier for you now
you have become predictable you can
predict easily what is that
going to happen ultimately so more and
more visibility you start getting so
handling things will become easier so
then it
allows for changes to refine and
re-prioritize the product backlog
so when i say product backlog we need to
understand the various different user
stories what is written to deliver
so that is a list of deliverables
product backlog what are there
since we already know what other things
needs to be created so this helps in
terms of prioritizing
those changing the priorities based on
the change scenario
and then taking the pace taking the
speed accordingly
the client can provide the priority of
features allowing the team to ensure
maximum project value so since it is
visible what are the user stories what
are the apex written
what is that order priorities order of
priority what we are kept
now the change scenario obviously tells
us do we really need to change this
priority of which feature has to be done
first so that will become easier because
you have the list
only changing that order in the list and
then going forward accordingly
integration is not an issue because we
have the base model which can integrate
all of this together with no issues
now then by focusing on needs of the
users the team can deliver value to the
customers
so users are involved more often so user
pulse is understood what user requires
is clearly understood
so delivering that value to the customer
will become more easier
and simpler so then project is broken
into smaller units
with high quality development testing
and collaboration because you have the
flexibility
so since you have better visibility you
can able to do this
and you move one by one iteration by
iterations
you progress further so those were the
advantages of
adopting agile now keeping that agile
manifesto on 12 principles of manifesto
so what are the types of typical agile
methodologies would come across
so there are few which we are going to
look at as part of it which we need to
know
so these agile methodologies definitely
considers
the agile manifesto points and then they
demonstrate it
in their own way now agile methodologies
perspective let us go one by one
so some of them to look at the first one
is
xp that is extreme programming so this
is the framework that enables teams to
create high quality software and
improves their
quality of life so it enables software
development with
appropriate engineering practices so and
then
when is it applicable so it is
applicable to the scenario where
changing
software requirements to handle risks
caused due to new technology
while working with a small extended
development team
to use technology to allow automated
unit
and functional tests so that is about
extreme programming
so next let us look at kanban so kanban
is a methodology which is
used to design manage and improve the
flow of systems
it is actually called as pull system so
visual system
so everything which is actually put on a
board and it is visible to everyone
what work need to be done what is in
progress who has to do it is very
clearly visible
so organizations can visualize their
flow of work and the limiting their work
in progress so what is limiting what is
stopping is clearly visible
so generally if i look at whenever i'll
just take a scenario of
a meeting and minutes of meeting which
always discuss about it
now when there is a minutes of meeting
shared with many people who have
participated in the meeting there are
certain action items given to them
for example now these action items i
will have a target date to complete
and accordingly those needs to be closed
now when the next meeting happens when
you look at that action item status
majority of them are not addressed what
could be the reason is that people are
not sensitive about answering or
addressing those so more than that the
prioritization changes
so one important thing we need to
understand how kanban works here is
it is a visual system compared to that
minutes of meeting which is not visible
to us always
the kanban board is visible to us always
so one which is visible to us always
makes us put a conscious effort to close
it because our name is indicated on the
board
the work need to be completed is
mentioned against our name
then we need to take it up and then
close it so it pushes it
it will put a conscious effort because
it is visible and
i cannot build any storage telling that
why i did not do why did i not
consider this as a priority rather than
consider something else as a priority
so this kanban straight up addresses it
and then
it's also called as pull system because
people pull the work from it
and then complete right so where is this
applicable
it can be used in situations where work
arrives in an
unpredictable fashion so that means it
gives lot of flexibility in terms of
adopting to the changes which are
happening the dynamics environment
so it is also used to deploy work
immediately without waiting for other
work items
so since it is visible i think things
can go smoother
easier so that people are owning it
rather than just disowning it
so now let us look at lean so when we
say lean it is very important for us to
understand
that value is always in customer
perspective
and elimination of waste these are the
two things mainly spoken about
so lean is a set of tools and principles
that aims to identify
and remove waste to increase the speed
of process development
it focuses on maximizing the value to
the client ensuring
waste is minimized so when you look at
visualize up processes
process interfaces and the flow so the
interface certain way so unless
the output of one process or procedure
is getting into an
another process so that flow should be
smoother like
many pipes connected together and water
is flowing
so let us assume series of pipes which
is of around
one feet in terms of diameter of each of
the pipes
water is flowing in between if you have
a pipe which is of
half a feet now what happens to the
downstream after that
half feet pipe the entire capacity in
the downstream
even though it has one feet diameter
pipe it leads to the waste
under utilized capacity because this has
become bottleneck
now such bottlenecks such the one which
contributes to the waste has to be
eliminated
that is very important so value should
be seen in the consumer perspective
and that value would happen only through
the series value streams
then in this value stream the
identification of the constraints and
bottlenecks
and elimination of waste now what are
the contributors of waste
so waiting time more often changing
things
moving from one place to another place
allowing defects to flow which leads
towards a rework
so all this likewise many things which
actually end up in
giving the ways so one has to visualize
understand realize
what are those non-valuing activities
and eliminating those
is very important right so now when is
it applicable
lean principles apply to any sector
where there is waste of
any form so it can be applied easily so
one is to
know that so that it should effort which
needs to be put with the
objective to accomplish so your ability
to move faster
your ability to create that product
which is more efficient
so only you can achieve it the effective
results can happen only when there is a
lesser delays or lesser waste
non-valuing activities that needs to be
understood and eliminate those
so next one of the populace methodology
would be scrum
so scrum is a framework that is used by
teams to establish
a hypothesis trying it out reflect on
the experience and digest
it is used to enable teams to
incorporate practices from other
frameworks depending on the team's
requirement
it's a simple framework which speaks
about a product owner
a scrum master a self-organizing team
so some of the terminologies what it
uses is sprint
daily scrum product backlog sprint
backlog
so it's very essential to understand
this framework simpler
and able to adopt it is also very easy
when is it
applicable it is used when
cross-functional teams are working on
product development
when work is split into more than one
two to four week iterations
so these iterations are called as
sprints
small time boxed iterations so this will
also help in terms of accomplishing the
results
provides that flexibility and able to
move faster
then crystal so crystal is an approach
to the software
development that focuses on people and
their interactions
rather than tools and processes it is
aimed to streamline processes
and improve optimization it works on
principle that
projects are unique and dynamic
each requiring its specific methods so
where is it applicable
it focuses on strengthening teams
communication
it also focuses on continuous
integration
active user involvement and configurable
processes
so these are the few agile methodologies
which are there which are more popular
more heard however we can come across
many other methodologies like safe agile
which is a scaled scenario for more
complex projects
so likewise we have many methodologies
which organizations adopt
and these are few for us to understand
so that's about
understanding what is agile thank you so
much for being here
hope this particular tutorial helped you
to understand the basic information
required to
know by a practitioner of agile so
thank you so much take care so until
then we see you next
time have a great time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here